so here's the Facebook [ __ ] now they're
changing their name to meta I'm old
enough to remember when Facebook was you
know college kids trying to get laid by
the way if Facebook was still
functioning like that we wouldn't need
cool mom to be driving kids around
getting them slammed but because
Facebook is no longer functioning as a
dating app for children it is now
functioning as a place for elderly
people to scream into the void to post
pictures of their dead dogs to talk
about their knee operations and and to
start you know these long threads where
people are trying to educate each other
on all manner of topics
they and they think the problem with
Facebook is misinformation all social
media's misinformation whether it's
Russia or your mother-in-law everybody
on Facebook is lying
and so you have a whistleblower and this
[ __ ] comes out and Facebook is now
changing their name to meta which is
weird because a restaurant Long Island I
like did that still good restaurant
Facebook fails to moderate harmful
content in developing countries what did
this whistleblower do why is she
what is the big deal here basically
she's saying that they're focusing they
they care more about profit than the
safety of their users so they allow
hateful content and hate groups and
people like that to spread tons of
misinformation that gets people but
those are their users
hate groups are your users
if someone's starting a hate group on
your platform they are a user are they
not
quote Facebook was aware that Maids were
being sold on its platform
internal documents show that Facebook
admitted it was quote under enforcing on
confirmed abusive activity when it
failed to take action after a Filipina
Maids complained of being abused and
sold on the platform according to the
Associated Press quote in our
investigation domestic workers
frequently complained to their
recruitment agencies of being locked up
in their home starved forced to extend
their contracts and definitely unpaid
and repeatedly sold to other employers
without their consent one Facebook
document read
in response agencies commonly told them
to be more agreeable it's not horrible
advice
so what is it is it Facebook's fault
that people are using Facebook to buy
and sell Maids yeah in like the January
6th stuff and should I post a status
right now anybody want a maid
I'm gonna post your status and see if it
gets taken down
Let's test this right now I'm gonna do
it to see if it actually works here okay
I'm posting your status right now
what's on your mind does anyone want a
maid I have one chained up in my
chained up
in my basement she will work you can hit
her
and then under it I'm gonna write test
see that does anyone want a maid I have
one chained up in my basement she will
work you can hit her test
post
let's see what happens okay I was
unaware of this that people were buying
and selling Maids is this only in the
Philippines uh yeah so they're really
bad at managing things in other
countries because they can't
speak the language very well so then
there's like hate groups in like India
against like Muslims you are determined
to sell a maid aren't you gonna sell a
maid
I mean this is the reality
how many roadblocks do we have to put up
before people realize that if you were
what do you mean the AI struggles with
non-english languages isn't this a
highly sophisticated artificial
intelligence system for like English
yeah they can't understand Filipino
apparently not it says they support 50
languages when in reality most of those
languages get a tiny fraction of the
safety systems that English gets so they
kind of with the other countries they
just kind of let them run amok
is the status okay did they take it down
is still up nice see maybe this is a
problem
the Wi-Fi is not good here
I have five likes
does anyone want a maid I have one chain
up in my basement she will work you can
hit her
see look like Myanmar they couldn't
identify hate speech in Ethiopian
languages
uh so there was no safeguards for those
countries
well what are they doing that's so bad
I don't care about hate speech I'm more
concerned with the selling and the of
the maids well yeah that's that's the
worst thing to me don't you think the
maids are like can we stop focusing on
the hate speech I'm in a closet
I'm getting hit with a broom
doesn't that make more sense yeah
Facebook's algorithm is takenly banned a
hashtag referencing the quote Al-Aqsa
mosque in Jerusalem's Old City because
they thought it represented the military
group Al-Aqsa Martyrs Brigade who are we
like we are like them
uh an armed off shoot is a secular fatah
party document show a lot of our fans
are not some artist Brigade
the company later apologized but The
Accidental removal of content serves as
a shining example I love that serves as
a shining example for how the social
media Giants algorithms can stifle
political speech due to language
barriers and lack of resources outside
of North America
so this whole thing's about languages
yeah something I smell a rat
I don't agree with this
this can't be about that you don't
understand
what uh can I does anyone have a maid in
Filipino language in Telugu or whatever
the hell they speak
I want to beat my maid in Filipino
nobody understands what that is
hey my maid's dead anyone got another
one so as long as I write that in
non-english I'm okay
something's wrong but what about the
Whistleblower people say she's a creep
because the Greenwald made a point a lot
of this seems to be like okay we take uh
the power away from these Tech
oligopolies but then who gets it the
government does anyone feel better with
the government running the show you
don't think they're gonna ban you
they'll ban you this is her Francis
Haugen
where's she from uh let me see here
I know she's in Europe right now doing
this whole thing
this woman is a uh
is she like Snowden is she gonna have to
leave the country she's from Iowa city
is Zuckerberg gonna have her whacked
I mean zark why don't you grow some
balls and have this woman killed
truly let's play with this creep this
creep sad with the Sweet Baby Ray's
barbecue sauce on the back and I said
that he's this guy he doesn't you know
sweet baby he doesn't know that it goes
on the food he's just trying to like be
a human being but hey Zuck why don't you
grow some balls and have this
whistleblower [ __ ] whacked have her
killed have this [ __ ] killed she's
[ __ ] your [ __ ] up
so this is a stop being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and have her killed act like a [ __ ]
boss why don't you ever act like a boss
you always go into Congress and you're
always [ __ ] pale and weird and
[ __ ] equivocating get this [ __ ]
stomped out American History X style
make her bite the curb remember that
scene bite the curb with the boot
do it to this [ __ ]
I want you to watch or get killed Zuck
like khashoggi was getting tortured in
the MBS watched it again allegedly no
issues with them allegedly he was
watching it I want Zuckerberg to watch
this when we get killed let's see what
he has to say I'm on his side here a
little bit so this is the Rebrand with
uh meta so this is the sneak peek at the
Facebook metaverse now meta is going to
be a better place to sell the maids
is that what we're
because they're creating a world where
Maids will be sold
seamlessly
okay here we go I need a maid are you
coming yeah just gotta find something to
wear
all right perfect
oh hey Mark hey what's going on
whoa here's the deal
that big creature is the maid
they don't show the real maid because
she's bruised and bloody
so what Zuckerberg has done is he has an
avatar for his maid so that it disguises
the substantial physical damage he's
done to her continue this is brilliant I
respect this guy and for anyone confused
this is through VR goggles through like
you know right because if you were to
look at it in actuality you would just
see a bleeding Filipino maid uh-huh who
made this place it's awesome who made
this place the crater I met in L.A what
happened it is amazing this is cool it's
just like VR of course it's me hey you
know
I hear knocking in the in a garage what
happened to the man you were bluffing I
don't know I think she got sick the maid
got sick let's call her she's not around
anymore stop asking questions about the
[ __ ] maid hey should we deal you in
sorry I'm running late but you've got to
see what we're checking out there's an
artist going around Soho hiding AR
pieces for people to find wow
3D Street there's some there's people in
the Philippines going around hiding
mates
are you guys up on that or no were you
just concerned about the the augmented
reality how about the actual reality
we're made to get beaten with that on
your website is anyone concern with that
or not if you guys like it because you
guys can't uh decode check out this for
us Filipino language let's see this is
like after 9 11 when the CIA doesn't
understand Arabic I'm like no they
understand it fine when they plan the
attack
they were like well they the CIA didn't
know anything about the attack because
they don't speak Arabic I said I think
they spoke it well when they were
training the hijackers in [ __ ]
Arizona anyway in Florida contact us for
brand deals